[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIM SNEATH: Let's now
switch to the developer.
Writing code can often
be a frustrating process,
particularly when you're
working with a new framework.
And perhaps one of the best
things about web development
is how immediate it is.
You can make
changes, and you can
see them reflected in real
time without the painful edit,
compile, run, debug
cycle that slows down
traditional development.
With Flutter, we've taken a lot
of inspiration from that model.
And here to show
you how fun it can
be to develop with
Flutter, Emily and Matt.
Hey, you guys.
EMILY FORTUNA: Hello.
[APPLAUSE]
MATT SULLIVAN: So
hopefully so far
you've seen a whole bunch of
really cool and beautiful apps
built in Flutter.
Well, we want to show you
something a little different,
what it's actually like to
build a Flutter app, what
the developer
experience is like.
So we've got a laptop.
We have a mobile phone.
And what we're
going to do is we're
going to start to play
around with some code
because one of the things
that we feel Flutter really
gives you as a developer is a
really, really nice development
experience.
So we're going to mirror our
mobile phone onto our laptop.
And we are going to get--
build ourselves an app.
And it's all going to go
swimmingly because this
is actually going to be live.
EMILY FORTUNA: Got a
ADB not responding.
MATT SULLIVAN: And we're
starting off really
well because our ADB
is not responding.
Yes.
[APPLAUSE]
I get to keep talking about
how wonderful the development
experience is.
EMILY FORTUNA: Why don't you--
MATT SULLIVAN: Not necessarily
the plugging the phone
and getting going experience.
EMILY FORTUNA: Why
don't you tell them
what we're going to build.
MATT SULLIVAN: OK.
So we're going to play
around with clocks
because we feel that clocks
are underrated as apps.
And we're going to actually
try to make them interesting.
But the real reason we're doing
it is because what we did was
initially, as you'll see any
second-- honestly I really,
really promise--
is that we put a very,
very basic app together.
And what this app is
is a countdown app.
And when we click go, it's
going to start counting down,
and we didn't put a
reset button in there.
So this is going
to count down to 0,
and that is going to
keep us honest as to what
we're going to build.
And we're going to
see how this goes.
So we're up and running.
Great.
We're going to take
about 30 minutes to--
EMILY FORTUNA: 15.
MATT SULLIVAN: We're
going to take 25 minutes--
EMILY FORTUNA: 15.
MATT SULLIVAN: We're
going to take 20 minutes--
EMILY FORTUNA: 10!
MATT SULLIVAN: Right, 15.
We're going to take 15 minutes--
EMILY FORTUNA: Let's split
the difference and make it 12.
MATT SULLIVAN: Emily runs down.
We're going to take 12 minutes,
and we're going to build a--
and you've already started.
OK.
So, Emily, why don't
we explain roughly
how our basic app works.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
So as Matt mentioned, we're--
we have a countdown app written
in Flutter because as you
can see it's rather boring.
But we're wondering what
if countdown apps could
be fun as Flutter is fun,
and what if count apps could
be beautiful.
This is not yet beautiful.
So let's take a look at
what we have written here.
So we've got a simple clock.
And if you ever come across a
clock in your lifetime, you--
MATT SULLIVAN: I hope you're
not going to explain clocks.
People get clocks.
And we have 11 minutes
and 24 seconds left.
EMILY FORTUNA: OK, so as
you will all experienced,
clocks tick.
Every second, a event--
time is passing.
And so what we
have here is we've
got a stream that our
program can subscribe to,
and every second an event occurs
saying the amount of remaining
time that is left.
And so we can subscribe
to the stream.
And on our simple clock, we
can build based on that stream.
So we have this stream builder.
We are listening to
that countdown stream.
And then based on each time
we get a update, AKA a second
has passed, we're going
to print that text.
MATT SULLIVAN: So the
moral of the story
here is time is
inexorably counting down,
and we need to get busy.
So we're going to make
our lives even more
harder because Emily
and I could not agree
on what we were going to build.
I wanted to build a retro clock
because I love my 70s chic.
EMILY FORTUNA: And I
wanted to showcase the fact
that we can use so
many different features
with our mobile phones.
So we're going to be
building a photo app
because interactive
timers are the best.
MATT SULLIVAN: So in 10
minutes and 15 seconds,
we are going to
try to build two.
And the reason again
we're using the stream is
because we can
actually build these,
and we can combine
them into this app.
And we can use the same
timer, so we cannot cheat.
So where am I going to start?
Let's take a look here.
Let's close that down.
And I am starting here with
basically a blank file.
I have nothing.
And I'm going to
start with a widget
because in Flutter everything
begins with a widget.
In the beginning,
there is a widget,
and I'm going to call
this retro clock.
EMILY FORTUNA: And as you
can see we have this widget
has a build method.
This is what's gets called
when you're drawing.
They would particular
widget to screen,
which is not yet being drawn.
And yeah.
MATT SULLIVAN: So what
screams 70s chic to you?
EMILY FORTUNA: Orange and brown.
MATT SULLIVAN: Orange and brown
is one but also wood grain.
So we're going to add
some wood grain in.
We're going to start there.
I bet you all thought you were
going to see something awesome,
and now you're going to
get retro wood grain.
And what I'm going to do is
I'm going to put in a stack.
And the reason I'm
using a stack is
that we can layer widgets on
top of each other with a stack.
And I'm going to start
with the wood grain.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yes.
And so right now this
stack has one widget in it,
but spoiler alert, there's
going to be more widgets on top.
MATT SULLIVAN: And
because we want
to be able to see all
of our clocks, what
are we going to use?
EMILY FORTUNA: Yes,
we'll add a-- we'll
wrap this in a page
view, which will allow us
to swipe between
the different clocks
since want to be able
to see all of them
as our time counts down.
MATT SULLIVAN: Yes, so
going to wrap page view.
We're going to put
retro clock first.
EMILY FORTUNA: Bold move.
MATT SULLIVAN: And
lo and behold--
oh, is this disconnected?
EMILY FORTUNA: It did!
MATT SULLIVAN: It
did disconnect.
This is going so well.
Oh, this is awesome.
I knew we should have
used the iOS simulator.
[LAUGHTER]
Bear with us while we
just reconnect here.
Now you see the problem here
is that we're not only counting
down.
So the app restarts.
It doesn't start at the same--
or at a new time or
at the beginning time.
We're persisting
this to the device.
So it's probably still clicking
down at this moment in time.
So we're not going
to get anymore
extra time to work in this.
We're going to be able
to constrain ourselves
even further.
So with Flutter,
even though it isn't
quite obvious to you at the
moment, what you can actually
do is you can develop really
nicely with a phone plugged in.
And you can hot reload
over to that phone,
and it could be iOS or Android.
We work equally well with
emulators and simulators.
And I even do
funky things like--
[LAUGHTER]
Did I mess up?
EMILY FORTUNA: You added a
few too many parentheses.
MATT SULLIVAN: Did I add
too many parentheses?
EMILY FORTUNA: Yes.
MATT SULLIVAN: Did
I actually do that?
EMILY FORTUNA: Yes.
Although that--
MATT SULLIVAN: Why
do I have a job.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah,
creating empty--
MATT SULLIVAN: I
used to write lists.
This was easy back then.
EMILY FORTUNA: Let's--
MATT SULLIVAN: Can
I keep going now?
EMILY FORTUNA: Yes.
MATT SULLIVAN:
Are we doing that?
Do you trust me?
EMILY FORTUNA:
It's re-launching.
MATT SULLIVAN: Will I actually
get back at the keyboard now?
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
Go for it.
MATT SULLIVAN: OK.
I'm going for it.
Wow.
EMILY FORTUNA: So while that's
reloading, as we mentioned,
we've stored our time in.
The preferences.
Oh, there we go.
MATT SULLIVAN: Oh dear me!
It's wood grain.
Yes.
Yeah, we go.
Yeah, wood grain wonderful.
[APPLAUSE]
EMILY FORTUNA: If only we
knew what time it was, Matt.
MATT SULLIVAN: If only
we knew what time it was,
it's too late.
And so what I'm going to
do is I am going to-- here,
I'm going to put
back in simple clock
because with simple clock,
everything is a widget,
and we can reuse widgets.
And lo and behold, we have
an incredibly difficult time
that we can't read, so let
me style that up a bit.
And we will put that in.
So we have eight minutes, and
we've gotten to wood grain
on a clock.
EMILY FORTUNA: I think you've
achieved Swedish minimalism.
MATT SULLIVAN: I think.
So let me fix that.
I'm going to put in
a clock frame widget.
And in my clock frame widget,
what I'm going to use here
is I'm going to use a card.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
So a card is--
it's just like a container.
You can give it color,
and it has some elevation.
It has a nice edge--
you can around the edges.
Make it stand out.
MATT SULLIVAN: Exactly and
again, I can just swap out
my widgets as I build this up.
And there we go.
We have a card, which
is kind of boring.
So let's make a
little more framing
so I can give it a shape,
and I can give it the border.
And this border-- border color,
some roundness, and there we
go.
OK so that's looking
more clock like right?
EMILY FORTUNA: That
is although I thought
this is just a retro
clock, and this
is looking pretty darn digital.
MATT SULLIVAN: OK, so I can
do something about that.
I can create you another widget
and start to stack them up,
and this time I'm going
to create a clock face.
And what I'm going to do
now is I'm going to use--
and cheat-- and I'm going
to use a package built
by one of our community.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah, so
someone else in our community
wrote this really cool
package called Flip Panel.
And Matt wrote some
styling around that,
and he has a variant
called Flip Digit.
And we are using that.
MATT SULLIVAN: But
we have a problem.
Because I'm no longer
using Retro Clock--
Simple Clock, so I don't
actually have a clock anymore.
So I need access to
that countdown stream.
EMILY FORTUNA: So, yeah,
Matt is going to access--
use a InheritedWidget to
pull down that stream so we
can listen and receive updates.
MATT SULLIVAN: And I'm going
to swap out my Simple Clock now
with my clock face.
And there we go.
Best clock ever.
[APPLAUSE]
Wait.
Wait, there's more.
We're not done yet.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah,
but I would like
to see how many minutes we have.
MATT SULLIVAN: You don't want
to see how many minutes we
have left, seriously.
EMILY FORTUNA: You're right.
I don't.
Let's just -- yeah, OK, fine.
MATT SULLIVAN: Can I
close my parentheses?
No I can't.
So let's reuse that.
So what I'm doing
here is I'm simply
creating a row so I can lay
things out horizontally.
And I'm going to put in
four flip digits, one
for each the tens, the
seconds, the ones and what not.
And I'm going to save that.
And there we go.
I think at this point,
this is retro enough.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah.
Yeah, it's good.
And I'm ready to take
over the keyboard.
MATT SULLIVAN: I'm
getting kicked off.
OK, fair enough.
Good.
So hopefully you've seen if
you balance your parentheses,
coding Flutter is
relatively straightforward,
composing widgets together.
And what I've done is I've
created something with--
basically by styling
up a bunch of pieces,
a little bit of animation
of using a package.
We're going to get a
little more advanced now
because what Emily wants
to build is a photo clock.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yes.
MATT SULLIVAN: So
what Emily's using
here is she's using a
stateful widget, which is--
I was using stateless
because I didn't
have any state to follow.
Emily is going to have
a little bit of state
to manage later on, and we'll
get back to that in a minute
when it becomes obvious.
So we have this stateful widget.
And inside what are we doing
when we run this thing?
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah, so when
you-- with stateful widgets,
you had this init state
method that you can call when
the first time that a
stateful widget is called.
Hold on.
I'm just going to
point that clock here
so we know how we're doing.
MATT SULLIVAN: So you can
see here that we have--
we're using the
camera plugin, which
is one of the plugins built
by the Flutter team, which
gives you full access to all
of the cameras and camera
activities, slash things you
can do on both iOS and Android.
And what we want
to do is we want
to take a photo every
minute, and we really
want to hurry up because we only
have 4 and 1/2 of them left.
So we're going to--
Emily's done some funky
math to basically say
every time we hit 0 on the
seconds, take a picture.
We're doing the right
thing with permissions?
EMILY FORTUNA: Yeah, what you
saw is I initialized the camera
and so it was asking me for
permissions to use the camera.
MATT SULLIVAN: And so
technically in seven seconds,
we're going to
get a photo taken.
So we shall do our first selfie.
And by the power of Flutter,
there was a photo taken.
Isn't that wonderful?
We have our word for it, so
let's actually show something.
EMILY FORTUNA: All right.
So I'm going to put
this in a column
so we can put the clock
and then the image
that we took just below it.
And then I wrote a widget
ahead of time called Film Strip
that's--
so remember we're talking
about streams for the time.
We also set up a stream that is
listening to the file system.
So when we take a photo, we
are writing to init file system
and we have a listener.
And then when that
is updated, we
tell Flutter that
we need to rebuild.
So I'm going to add that in.
MATT SULLIVAN: We're
going to add this in.
We're using a column here.
I used the row earlier, so this
should vertically stall it.
And fingers crossed,
we have a selfie.
[APPLAUSE]
So this is great.
We can only-- well,
we're going to need--
EMILY FORTUNA: There's
another picture coming up.
MATT SULLIVAN: All right,
so I'm going to get in here.
I'm going to get my selfie.
This is going to be great.
So we got 3, 2, 1 and photos.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
We're going to make this
so we can scroll back
to the other photo right?
EMILY FORTUNA: Yes.
Oh, well, yes, because I
like the first one better.
So let us switch this is out.
Right now we're just
checking-- we're showing
the first of the film images.
So instead, we're going
to use a list view.
And we're going to
scroll horizontally
through all of the photo paths.
MATT SULLIVAN: And
so we have managed
to squeeze in stacks,
columns, rows, and list views
almost by accident,
but we got them all in.
So now we can scroll
through these photos,
and this is great.
And we're starting
to get somewhere.
But we're not quite
done yet are we.
EMILY FORTUNA: No, I'm
going to add some styling.
So first--
MATT SULLIVAN: Even though
I eat up all your time,
you seem to be making
some up, and we still
have 2 minutes and
10 seconds left.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yes.
So first I'm going to
add some images just
to make it look a little
more like a camera.
Uh oh.
I'm glad that Dash could visit.
MATT SULLIVAN: There we go.
EMILY FORTUNA: She may have
even visited the haberdashery.
So I'm also going to set some
styling to make this fill in.
Let's see.
I've got a nice font.
MATT SULLIVAN: So we're
going to style up the time,
and we're going to make
it not look super modern.
We're going to go art deco.
This is going to
be fairly eclectic.
So we have the
time ticking down.
We have some styling around it.
What else do we need to do?
Oh, we're going to put in a--
we have two cameras in
this phone, not one.
And we can access both of them.
So what we can do here is
we can pop in a button,
and that's going to let us--
EMILY FORTUNA: Switch the
direction of the camera.
MATT SULLIVAN: Switch the
EMILY FORTUNA: So it's
pretty easy button.
You can see here, when we when
the can't-- when the button
gets pressed, we are going
to switch the direction
of the camera.
And this is where the
statefulness of the widget
comes into place.
We're setting the state,
and here I'll show you.
So you see that?
If you tap the button, you
can see the text will change.
And so it's changing state.
Now the alignment
is a little wonky,
so I'm going to fix that.
Make it centered.
And there's one more
thing we're going to do.
MATT SULLIVAN: We
have 35 seconds.
What are we going to do?
EMILY FORTUNA: So
there's a really cool--
another third-party plug-in that
has this explosion animation.
And so I--
MATT SULLIVAN: We're going
to make our app self-destruct
in 22 seconds.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yes.
So I wrote--
MATT SULLIVAN: Not that we
made it self-destruct already
at least twice.
EMILY FORTUNA: Yes.
Yes.
Well-- so we're going to--
MATT SULLIVAN: Are
we going to make it?
EMILY FORTUNA: We're
going to make it.
MATT SULLIVAN: OK.
We got 10 seconds.
EMILY FORTUNA: We
are going to make it.
MATT SULLIVAN:
House lights please.
I want everybody
raise their arms--
3, 2, 1.
Say cheese.
AUDIENCE: Cheese.
MATT SULLIVAN: Oh, look at that!
There we go!
[APPLAUSE]
Fireworks!
EMILY FORTUNA: Phew!
MATT SULLIVAN: We've subjected
you enough life coding,
so we'll stop it there.
Thank you very much.
EMILY FORTUNA: Get
you enough adrenaline.
Rest easy now.
[APPLAUSE]
TIM SNEATH: I have so much
respect for those guys
to pull that off in that
length of time is just amazing.
So over the last couple of
months, we spent a lot of time
talking with companies
and developers who're
building with Flutter
and learning a little bit
about how they're using it.
And in particular as
we've got towards 1.0,
we were interested to
see what things did we
need to continue to invest in.
And so there's a bunch
of things that we've
been working on and adding
over the last couple of months,
particularly in the
run up to Flutter 1.0.
So firstly developers told
us, as Will mentioned,
they wanted to see
support or better support
for building apps that
fully model the iOS design
guidelines.
So we've added lots more
widgets and classes that
make it possible to build
those pixel perfect experiences
for iPhone.
Secondly, as Phillip
showed, developers
want to be able to
integrate other platform
content into Flutter apps.
So we've done the
heavy lifting work
to bring this directly into
the Flutter compositor,
and so that's how you
saw the Google Maps work.
And in the last week we've
published developer previews
of a Google Maps plugin and
also a web browser plugin.
And then we heard loud
and clear the developers
want to be able to add
Flutter to existing apps
rather than just creating
new apps with Flutter.
This has actually been
possible for a while.
But we've done a lot of work
over the last couple of months
to improve the tooling, the
build process, the debugability
of this scenario.
And we'll continue to
invest in this space
over the next couple of months.
And, of course, that's not
all that's in Flutter 1.0.
We fixed a bunch of bugs.
We've continued to
refine and polish it.
One feature I'm
particularly proud of
is adding localization
of the UI content
to 50 languages from Arabic
to Vietnamese, Marathi
to Swiss German.
We even support English.
Many of these have come thanks
to community contributions,
so thank you if you've been
involved in that process also.
Lastly, Flutter 1.0
includes Dart 2.1,
which adds additional
compile time
checking, increased performance,
and reduced code size.
A recent study of
GitHub pull requests
shows that Dart is one of the
fastest growing languages,
and that's also backed up by
the latest edition of the TIOBE
index.
And as you'll see later,
Dart gives Flutter
unique advantages because of
its versatility as a platform.
So we've done design.
We've done develop.
We're now going
to move on to talk
about another part of
the development process,
connecting to external services.
As I mentioned earlier,
one of the reasons
why Flutter is so productive
for mobile development
is the package ecosystem.
We deliberately made the core
of Flutter as small as possible,
and we use the plug-in
model ourselves to shape
new features out of band.
We already have over
1,000 Flutter plugins,
covering everything
from video playback
to Facebook authentication,
SQL lite to graph QL.
These packages are
fully open source.
Many of them are contributed
by the community.
And they make it easy to add
support for new services.
For mobile developers,
Firebase provides an array
of key app services such
as analytics, databases,
sign in, push notifications,
and crash reporting.
Most of them are
already supported
with first-party
Flutter integrations.
And further 1.0 increases
this support further.
To show how these
plug-ins come together
to make Flutter apps
even more connected,
please welcome Maurice
Parrish to the stage.
Maurice, great to see you.
MAURICE PARRISH: Thank you, Tim.
Let's get logged in here.
Make sure everything's
connected.
So it looks like we went
out to reconnect this.
Here we go.
Perfect.
Hey, everyone.
My name's Maurice, and
I'm an engineer that
works on Flutter's plugins.
I would like to
show you something
cool that we've been
adding to Flutter.
As you can see here, we
have an avatar of me.
And just like the timeline
app, the design and animation
have been provided using Flair.
Right now, the avatar
is just standing idle.
That's kind of boring.
So what we can actually do
is we can move these sliders.
We can have his
face animation move,
add some funny
expressions as well.
We can even give
them a big smile.
When instead of using
sliders, what have we
could have his facial expression
match mine automatically
using the power of
machine learning.
So let's look at the code.
So to achieve this, we're
going to need two plugins.
We're going to need
the camera plugin,
and we're going to need
that ML kit plugin.
So since this app has already
been pre-configured to--
preconfigured for the
camera and the ML kit,
we're just going to dive
straight into the code.
So the first thing we're
going to need to do
is we're going to need to create
a class that will facilitate
taking images from the
camera and passing it
to the face detector.
So I've already gone
ahead and created
a class called Face Expression
Reader that does just that.
So this class has
three main components.
It has the camera controller,
which controls access
to the camera, then we
have the face detector,
which runs ML models on
images to detect faces.
The last part is we had the init
method, which sets everything
up.
So what we're going
to do is we're going
to implement the init method.
And what I love about
Flutter is how easy
it is to get started
with the camera.
It only requires two lines.
The first one is a
constructor, where
we show that we want
access to the front camera.
And the second one, we show that
we want low resolution images.
And then the second line, we
just initialize the camera.
That's all that we need.
The next step is
initialize the detector.
And just like the camera,
it's just as easy to setup.
All we do is we get an
instance of face detector
from Firebase vision.
However, the default
face detector
only tells you the location
of faces in an image.
So what we're
going to want to do
is really set some
options so it can actually
read facial expressions.
Here we go.
Reformat.
So the options
we're going to set
so we can read
facial expressions
is to-- we're going to enable
classification and have
the detector run
in accurate mode.
Now last but not
least, we're going
to want to continuously
stream bytes from the camera
to the detector,
and I've already
gone ahead and created a
helper method to do just that.
So in this method,
all we do is we
pass the camera and the
detector we just initialized
but also pass a method that
updates the face expressions
reader every time we get a
new result face from an image.
So we can actually take a quick
look at this helper method.
It's actually fairly short.
All we really do is we call this
upcoming method called start
byte stream on the camera.
Every time we get an
image, we take this image,
we pass it to our
detector, and then
after we get the results
for our detector,
we update our face
expression reader.
So now that we set
all that up, let's
go ahead and go to
our main dot Dart.
We're going to want to go
down to our statement or state
class.
So I've already gone ahead and
created an instance of the face
expression reader, the class
we just implemented, and I
called it reader.
So the very last thing we
need to do to get this working
is that we needed to add
a listener to the reader.
And here we go.
Now with this listener,
the face expression reader
will update our avatar every
time it gets a new face.
So we're going to go
ahead and run hot restart.
And the reason we're going
to run hot restart instead
of hot reload is because since
we changed our init state
method, we want to rebuild
the entire state of our class.
Let's see.
I think it's already set up.
There you go.
There we go.
[APPLAUSE]
So not only can it just
tell if I'm smiling or not,
we can actually add
a little bit more.
So we're going to go ahead
and run another hot restart.
And what we did is
that we have the--
we're going to update
the eyes, and we're
going to update the
tilting of the head.
So if I hold this up to my
face again, close my eyes,
tilt right and left, it
updates in real time.
[APPLAUSE]
So now that you've seen how easy
it is to use ML Kit, hopefully
you'll consider it
using your app as well.
Thanks, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
TIM SNEATH: Thanks, Maurice.
So as Flutter is now
at the point where
it's starting to gain
this critical momentum,
we're starting to see
other major companies add
direct support.
As an example, today, we're
announcing a new partnership
that we think will open Flutter
to a new class of applications.
Mobile phones that
are increasingly
being used for payments, both
for digital and physical goods.
Square are one of the
pioneers of payment services
for retailers and consumers.
And I'm delighted to introduce
Ella Polo to the stage
to talk about how you guys
are extending Flutter.
Welcome.
ELLA POLO: Thank you, Tim.
At Square, we believe
the economy is better
when everyone has access.
No one should be left out
because the cost is too high
or the technology too complex.
We started with a
little light reader
that let millions of merchants
participate in the economy
by making it easy
to take credit card
payments with your smartphone.
Since then, we've worked hard to
create an ecosystem of products
that empowers our customers,
and our developer platform
is a key part of that ecosystem.
Our multi-channel
payment platform
includes APOs and SDKs that let
developers integrate payments
into the apps they build.
Square takes care of the
complexity of payments
in person, in app, and
online so developers can just
focus on building great apps.
Now we've been following
Flutter since the beta,
and we're impressed by
how it enables developers
to quickly create beautiful
and performance cross platform
apps.
That's why today, we're
so excited to announce
two new plugins for
Flutter development--
the Flutter plugin for
the Square Reader SDK
and the Flutter plugin for
the in-app payments SDK.
The Square Reader SDK enables
developers to build apps
for merchants that take
in-person payments using
Square hardware.
And the in-app
payments SDK lets them
build consumer apps that take
payments directly from buyers.
To see this in action, let's
meet Collins Family Orchards.
They're a great example of
a typical small business
that runs on Square.
Collins Family Orchards is a
fourth generation family farm
growing a variety of organic
foods in eastern Washington
state.
They sell their produce
at farmer's markets all
around the Seattle area.
And like many small
businesses, they
use their phone and a Square
reader to take payments.
Now the Collins family was
happy running on square,
but they wanted to build
an app to accommodate
the specific needs of
their growing business.
So let's take a look at
an app built specifically
for the Collins family using
Flutter and the Flutter
for Square Reader SDK plugin.
This app helps
them take and track
payments at each
farmer's market they
go to and has quick locations
switching built right in.
Can we see the app here?
Yes, it's on the right.
You can see that it's branded
for Collins Family Orchards,
and I'm going to
start by signing in.
And then I'll choose the
location that I'm selling at.
So let's say today that I'm at
a farmer's market in Bellevue.
Great.
And I'll enter the
amount of charge,
but we can see right now that
the charge button is disabled.
So let's take a look at
the code really quick.
This is the on
checkout function,
and this uses the Flutter
plug-in for Square Reader SDK
to start the Square
checkout flow.
It takes an a set of
checkout parameters,
and these are the
things that determine
the behavior of the
payment flow so things
like the amount
of the transaction
but also whether we want to
collect tips or show a receipt
screen.
And once we start
the checkout flow,
you'll notice that there's no
configuration for the reader
here, and that's because once
we're in the transaction,
Square takes care of
talking to the hardware.
So this is really all the
configuration that you need.
And we'll see nothing's calling
this check out functionary now.
So for the live coding
portion of the demo,
we're going to do a hot
reload and set the charge
button to call on check
out when it's pressed.
And then I'll click charge
to start the transaction.
Great.
What you're seeing now is
the Square check out outflow
if I can find my card.
Can we see the reader?
Yes.
And I'll insert my card
to take the payment.
[BEEPING]
Great.
And the payment was accepted.
Now when we look at the list of
transactions for this location,
we can see the payment that
I just took right there.
[APPLAUSE]
As you can see, it's
really easy to add payments
into your Flutter
app with Square.
The Flutter plug-in for
the Square Reader SDK
is available today,
and the Flutter plugin
for the in-app payments SDK
is available for early access.
And you can read more about
both at Square Up dot com slash
Flutter.
We're really excited to be
partnering with Google on this
and to see what more we can
do with Flutter in the future.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
TIM SNEATH: Thank you,
Ella, and thank you Square.
So the last part of
the app lifecycle we're
going to talk about is release.
As you've been hearing
throughout the presentation,
our goal is to make Flutter
the most productive way
to build beautiful fast
experiences for both iOS
and Android from a
single code base.
But when it comes to
continuous integration,
continuous deployment,
sometimes feels
that we're still a little
bit stuck in the olden days.
It's just a little
bit too hard sometimes
to configure build and
test tooling, particularly
if you're trying to target
both iOS and Android.
Lots of knobs and switches
and manual configuration
sometimes feels like being a
phone operator in the 1950s.
If only there was a build
system that understood Flutter.
Well, turns out there's a
company who's been doing that.
Let me introduce Triin
Kask from Nevercode.
Hi, Triin.
[APPLAUSE]
TRIIN KASK: Hello, everybody.
I'm so excited to be here
and celebrate this Flutter
live event with people
here and online.
So, hey, people online.
So at Nevercode,
we've been building
our continuous integration
and delivery product
for mobile developers
in companies
such as Toyota, Walmart, and
Sainsbury's to name a few.
And we've seen them
struggle with setting up
the whole development process
for iOS and Android separately.
So when we heard
what Flutter does
and how it actually changes
the way-- how mobile apps are
developed, we were convinced
that the whole CI/CD experience
needs to be re-engineered.
So I'm proudly presenting you
our brand new product Code
Magic.
[APPLAUSE]
So I'm going to show
you how it works.
And I'm going to
show how easy it
is to set up the whole
pipeline to build your Flutter
apps on Code Magic.
So actually the
beauty starts already
when you join with
your GitHub account
because you see it automatically
understands your Flutter apps
and pulls them to Code Magic.
And it's very easy.
You just kick off the
first build and voila.
It starts.
You see the whole process
here on one screen.
So, of course,
normally you would
have web hooks that trigger
the builds from GitHub
after each commit.
But the underlying thought when
we were building this product
was that it needs
to be seamless.
It needs to be intuitive
so that even a person
with no prior CI/CD experience
can start very, very quickly.
So just to demonstrate
to you some
of the UI that we have in mind,
for example I'm taking this--
oh, there's a huge--
OK, here's your fail build.
Because you want to know why
things are failing sometimes,
so here you see that it--
the build fail because it
failed to install dependencies
and here you get
more information
like what's happened to
make the next decisions.
And then if you want to
configure your app more
on Code Magic because it's
not just for hobbyists
or freelance results, also
for hardcore developers
who maybe want to experience
a more sophisticated product.
So you just go to the
app settings here.
You see seems like
just small steps,
but actually you can
customize here a lot.
For example, I have
chosen that I only
want to build the Android app.
And, for example, in publishing,
you can publish automatically
to Google Play or app store, and
we also support out-of-the-box
integration code signing
with iOS and Android.
So as I'm on Slack very
often then, of course,
I want my notification to
end up in Slack channel,
so I have chosen
here that I want
to know when the build
starts and when it fails
or when the artifacts
are published.
So let's go see how far are we
building this app currently.
So you see that it's currently
building the Android app,
and already you can open up
the steps to see everything
what's going on here.
So it gives you a
lot of flexibility.
And another thing
that I also wanted
to mention that if I
go here to app settings
is that you can also actually
[INAUDIBLE] your workflows
according to the user groups.
Maybe you want to have
them different people--
to, testers beta testers, some
other team in your company.
It shows that the
build was successful.
So I'm just going
to do the build.
And here everything is green.
It's a very nice green.
So I promise that they
should be on Slack,
so let's go check
out my Slack channel.
And they are!
Great!
The artifacts are actually here.
[APPLAUSE]
So I'm convinced that
Flutter plus Code
Magic is the fastest
route to get your apps
to the hands of your end users.
So I invite everybody to join
and sign up at codemagic.io.
It's free.
It's live now.
You can just go crazy.
And then you can also
join our Slack channel
where all the other Flutter
fans are and just share
your experience,
learn from others.
So I think it will be awesome.
Thank you.